as the movie begins we see Chen Chia Hao
lying injured in the middle of the
street how is a young idealistic cop
assigned to traffic Duty who possesses
exceptional mental and physical strength
however he is plagued by an uncanny
ability to perceive what others cannot
ghosts of the dead as a result despite
his remarkable skills he has only risen
to the level of a traffic cop as how
reminisce is about his past we find that
he has had this ability since childhood
which caused him to be alienated and
mocked by other children following this
we are taken back to the incident that
resulted in Howe's injury one night
while on routine Patrol house partner
notes his peculiar behaviors that get
him in trouble such as how simply
launching himself into the air in front
of vehicles from house perspective he is
diving in front of running cars to save
jaywalker's spirits but to an average
person it appears as if he is
deliberately provoking a collision as
the two continue discussing a car races
straight past them but Hal manages to
stop it in interrogates the driver for a
while and warns him to take it slow the
next time but as Hal prepares to let him
go he spots traces of Blood on the car's
trunk how opens it to inspect it more
closely but Ollie uncovers is a pink
purse just then the driver slams him
with a heavy object in the head knocking
him to the ground he also shoots house
partner in the heart killing him
instantly the man then prepares to
finish off how but at the same time a
female ghost escapes from the trunk and
materializes in front of him this gives
how the opportunity to bring out his gun
and shoot the assailant instead the
following day Howe explains to his
seniors that a female ghost intervened
on his behalf and saved him but as
expected No One Believes him in addition
he is asked to revise his report by
leaving out all the references to the
ghost enraged that no one is believing
his story how quits the job instead
shortly after detective Chang who
appears to be the only one to comprehend
his point of view approaches him how is
that offered to be recruited for his
secret police crime Euro then detective
Chang Scouts him to the ninth Precinct a
special yet secret pseudo segment of the
police agency that deals with mysterious
unsolved cases particularly those
involving ghosts and helps them find
peace to let them pass on as soon as
Howe enters the department he notices
other police officers that are
interacting with ghosts and have the
same abilities as himself detective
Chang then explains to him that when a
person dies and becomes a ghost they
feel confused he adds that they're held
among the living until their Earthly
grievances are soft and they're helped
to properly pass over to the other side
Howe admits that he can see the ghosts
but not hear them so the detective
simply advises him to empathize more
with his heart until he gains the
ability to hear them then detective
Chang briefs him on the most important
weapons used in a supernatural
investigation the first thing he
mentions is incest
incense which is a medium to help
communicate our thoughts and enable
interactions with the Dead next is a
special yin yang umbrella that protects
the ghosts and lastly a sacred water
pistol to defend oneself and Destroy
malicious and vengeful Spirits following
this Howe is introduced to sue a tough
and mystical detective who seems to be
acting rather bizarrely detective Chang
reveals that she is being possessed by
the master a spirit that abruptly
possesses her and provides helpful
guidance to solve their cases however
the master can only be controlled
through the excessive consumption of
alcohol right strangely as soon as the
possessed Suey comes closer to Hal the
master detects a woman's Spirit
following him later that day detective
Chang and Hao had out on a case where a
woman reports her house being haunted
with strange noises and ghostly
apparitions of a child as they begin
their investigation the detective asks
how to make use of the yin yang umbrella
and immediately upon opening it a ghost
of a child appears before him then the
detective does some investigation and
realizes that the child's parents didn't
have the ritual done properly after his
death which trapped his soul there he he
adds that a child whether human or ghost
Longs for their mother's warmth and
affection and for someone to play with
eventually he wraps up the case by
revealing that the hauntings in the
house were actually the kid trying to
play with the woman living there not
realizing that he's dead as for the
solution the boy will be properly buried
the next morning giving him the peace he
always deserved next they returned to
the precinct and Hal suspects that the
woman's Spirit whom the master said was
following him is the one who actually
saved his life however detective Chang
strictly warns him to only police the
ghosts and not get involved with the
cases involving humans despite the
warning Hal meets the woman's Spirit
named Huang yahui who leads him to the
house she used to live in but just
moments after entering Hal gets knocked
out by her friend Zhu sin who thinks
he's an intruder thankfully yahweh's
Spirit helps him point to her diary and
makes you sin believe that he can see
her and is there to help at last juice
in reveals that her friend yahui has
been missing for over a month the next
day detective Chang and Hao had out on a
case where an old man reports
unidentified cries and Furniture
movements in his house but after a bit
of Investigation surprisingly it is
revealed that he's actually a spirit who
hasn't realized that he's already dead
when the old man finally learns of this
he helps the detectives find Clues
regarding his grief that has him trapped
in the Earthly realm following the clues
Hal finds a box which contains a photo
of the old man with his daughter this
implies that locating his daughter will
help him pass on to the other side
meanwhile Suey gets possessed and has a
vision of a place where his daughter is
so the three of them drive to the subtle
location only to find a crowd of female
ghosts all adorning the same robe and
staring at them with sadness and a tinge
of Hope how then carefully makes his way
to the old man's daughter reunites the
two of them and sets them free the same
night they inform other police
departments about this which helps them
exhume a mass grave of bodies all
identified as those of the women who had
been reported missing for the past few
months before leaving Howe notices Yahoo
among the crowd and due to his strong
sense of justice he tries to solve her
case however detective Chang wants him
to not meddle in the Affairs as it may
lead to disastrous consequences next we
are introduced to Sun yushu CEO at Sun
General Hospital who's just been
informed that a wealthy counselor has
met with an accident so without wasting
any time she departs to rescue him in
the next scene yushu is seen standing in
front of a statue of Satan bearing an
inverted cross and a dark robe she then
slowly proceeds to conduct a ritual of
rebirth on the deceased counselor
meanwhile Jew sin and how do some
digging and learn that yahuwah was
pregnant with the counselor's child and
had been to the sun General Hospital for
her delivery this is when she completely
disappeared surprisingly the rest of the
victims also never returned after their
visit to the same hospital this explains
why they were wearing the same gowns the
next day they pay yeshu a visit and
interrogate her about the disappearances
but as expected she feigns ignorance so
juice and bribes the guards and gains
access to the CCTV footage shockingly
the footage reveals that the counselor
is standing on both feet without any
scars despite having been in an accident
a few days ago in another video it has
shown that Yahoo did in fact visit the
hospital but she never managed to get
out elsewhere yushu gets Furious over
the two trying to cross her so she
summons an evil spirit and sends him to
harm them in the meantime the two get
back to juicin's house and just when how
is alone in the washroom the evil spirit
shows up nice dick it says they engage
in a fierce battle with both going back
and forth for a while in the end the
spirit gives up and leaves realizing
that he cannot compete with a Precinct
cop at the same time detective Chang
arrives at the scene and it is revealed
that juice in is his daughter however
they are not on good terms so she
angrily asks him to get out warning him
to stay away from her business detective
Chang obliges but after while he again
calls her to try and reconcile with her
they finally seem to be getting along
but just then yushu's men break into her
house and abduct her hearing his
daughter screams detective Chang rushes
to her place only to find it deserted he
does however find the CCTV footage that
she was watching before being taken away
as the detective looks closely he
notices yushu in the frame shockingly
growing horns out of her head realizing
that she is the perpetrator detective
Chang rushes over to the hospital there
he meets yushu and tries to persuade her
into giving his daughter back in
exchange for the evidence but she
refuses then with a diabolical grin she
exclaims that juice and sacrifice is a
necessity for other important lives
finally it is revealed that yeshua's
special powers as she is in League with
the devil she actually deprives her
young victims of their life force and
either absorbs it herself or feeds it to
her well-off clients leaving them
youthful forever hearing all of this the
enraged detective brings out his gun but
before he can pull the trigger yushu
shows him his daughter detective Chang
is horrified as he sees his daughter
lying unconscious in the middle of a
ritual surrounded by candles then with
just a touch of her hand you should
chokes him and threatens to finish him
off later that night several news
channels report that the detective has
committed the unthinkable to end his
suffering surprisingly the news also
states that he had been going to the
hospital for quite some time to cure his
depression this is because the cunning
issue has fabricated some papers to make
it look as if he carried out the ACT
himself yes the devil's number one skill
paperwork forgery the entire Precinct is
devastated to hear the news in
particular sway is deeply affected by
detective Chang's death as he had always
been a father figure to her how is not
having an easy time either as the two
had just begun to grow close as partners
he then gets in his car and softly
whimpers holding the flat paper dolls
that juice sin had made in her childhood
it is revealed that detective Chang
treasured these more than anything else
in the next scene 2A approaches how and
starts talking about her tragic
childhood she Begins by revealing that
she had two fathers one of them was a
sailor who drowned in the sea then when
she was three her other father adopted
her apparently he used to get drunk and
violently beat her every night without
fail then one night having had enough of
the abuse she ran away from home and
kept running until she collapsed she was
then brought to a temple where she lived
for many years with tears in her eyes
Suey then reveals that it was detective
Chang who found her and took her to that
Temple following this how also talks
about his childhood because nothing
makes a third act kick like a bunch of
unnecessary flashback sequences he
begins by revealing that a fortune
teller predicted that his father would
marry two wives therefore his father
ended up marrying a ghost woman to
fulfill the prophecy although his
intentions remain unclear however only
Hal could see his ghost mother who was
always there with him no matter where he
went but when his friends got to know
about this they started bullying him
badly tell us all about the ghosts you
little fed up with all of this now
began ignoring his mother and ran away
from her since that day he could neither
see nor hear his ghost Mother after the
emotional stories they decide to look
for juice sin and rescue her for this
they abduct one of yushu's closest
employees and play Russian roulette with
him when the man gets shot in his
shoulder he finally spills all of
yushu's Secrets including the fact that
she can only be defeated by the Sacred
Water oh yeah the water guns why didn't
we try those as a result how and Sue
rushed to the hospital armed with only
the sacred water pellet guns along the
way to the ritual room they fight
hand-to-hand combat with guards and
shoot ghosts with guns just as Hal
enters the room he sees yushu praying to
Satan and placing Jews in as the
offering he immediately Fires at her but
the bullets don't seem to work realizing
that he cannot defeat her how reverts to
plan B he pretends to surrender by
dropping his gun but as soon as he gets
near Yeshua he spits out the Sacred
Water on her inverted cross this undoes
all of her spells and leaves her
powerless how then takes juice in out of
the water and a detective Chang who has
come in the form of a spirit softly
calls out to her after a few seconds she
finally wakes up and immediately looks
for her father only to learn that he has
already passed away a few days later
Jason holds a funeral for detective
Chang and the entire ninth Precinct
attends it including the ghosts
meanwhile how goes home after the
funeral and finally sees his ghost
mother in the rain he walks down to her
and keeps her under the umbrella this
finally gives her the closure that she
has been desperate for for years the
movie ends as how lovingly looks at his
mother as she slowly Fades away
ends you know
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching